all right
time for this week's sin city chronicles
a weekly look back at vegas history and
happenings
and let's start with the corner of
flamingo and las vegas boulevard
today it's the home of valleys with over
2800 rooms and it has the show
jubilee from 1973 to 1986 it was the mgm
grand
and prior to the mgm it was the bonanza
hotel and casino
which opened in july of 1967. i love
these old photos
so the western theme hotel had 160 rooms
a 650 seat theater and opening night was
headlined by lauren green of the tv show
bonanza of course it was let's go from
bonanza to
[Music]
one of the biggest traveling musical
festivals of the 90s was lollapalooza
and in july 1994 the tour kicked off at
sam boyd stadium
11 000 people showed up which is
actually a low number
but we had the smashing pumpkins beastie
boys george clinton and others
now nirvana was going to headline the
tour but the band stepped down after
lead singer kurt cobain
took his life that april now we go from
90s music to
80s wrestling all right
ladies and gentlemen get ready this
great city of las vegas action city get
ready for the debut of the world
wrestling federation
out of the campus of the university of
nevada las vegas mack center
mac center thomas and mack center come
on mean gene july 10
1988 had classic wwf action at the
thomas and mack
four 000 fans were on hand to see stars
like brutus the barber beefcake
the honky tonk man and the main event
andre the giant
ah defeated hacksaw jim duggan vegas
world a space-themed hotel casino
opened on july 13 1979 it was owned by
bob stupec
and had 90 rooms the dallas cowboys
cheerleaders were the big guests on
opening night
the hotel that lasted 26 years and
eventually became
the strat now finally if you lived in
vegas in the 90s
you might remember this
[Music]
the maxim hotel opened in july of 1977
the 800 room property located at
flamingo just west of cobalt
had a popular following because of its
attention to detail they had a pot of
fresh coffee for you every morning
and if you put your shoes outside your
door they would be shined the next
morning
imagine doing that now you put your
shoes out one would be there in the
morning your shoes wouldn't be there
when you got back it wouldn't be
all right that's your sin city
chronicles for the second week of july
rocky over to you